well it's official tsm's league of
legends team have had their worst split
ever in their nine year history they've
been north american champions seven
times they've competed in all 18 splits
of the lcs and they've made playoffs
every single time
until now
this is their all-time low here's how it
happened
well would you look at that it's me
danny burke talking about tsm yet again
if that sounds like your cup of tea then
make sure you're subscribed to the score
esports it's not just me on the channel
either believe it or not and we don't
just talk about tsm or league of legends
there's a whole bunch of stuff trust me
you won't regret it so tsm are not going
to be in the lcs playoffs there's
something i thought i would never say
someday directly in the base he takes
down the nexus turret so no dsm if you
can't make this stand you have
officially for the first time missed out
on playoffs in the history of the
organization 100 thieves out on top to
be honest even as the losses were
racking up there was still a chance they
could make it i was hanging out in the
tsm discord and there was genuine hope
that if the results fell the right way
for them tsm could do what they've done
every year since 2013 and make playoffs
but it was always going to be a tall
order after the first four weeks of the
lcs they'd only won a single game and
sat bottom of the table with a 1 8
record statistically though they still
had a chance to make it in week 7 tsm
fans were running dangerously low on
hopium supplies after tsm not only had
their first 2-0 weekend but took down
top of the table cloud9 in the process
speaker goes in and he finds summit
he'll get right back out without even
losing guardian angel
ladies and gentlemen where were you
win last place tsm dismantled first
place cloud nine and absolutely schooled
them gg tsm win now before we go any
further full disclosure i have to admit
that i am a tsm fan but if you've
watched any of my videos over the past
few months you'll know that i try to not
let it interfere with my job most of the
time but after witnessing that victory i
and a lot of other tsm fans were pretty
much maxed out on hopium not to go and
win the whole thing but just to make
playoffs and i mean that's kind of
understandable for a lot of fans the
memory of summer 2020 was still at the
back of their minds when tsm went on an
insane lower bracket run to win the lcs
against all odds the difference there of
course was that bjergsen and doublelift
were there helping tsm to won final
victory in what would be the last time
both of them played for the team little
did tsm fans know this would basically
be the last happy memory for them a year
and a half ago the team failed to pick
up a single win at worlds crashing out
in the group stage with a zero and six
record but if 2020 was the year the tsm
car began to break down 2021 was the
year the wheels really came off now some
of you guys may know the story from this
point you might have seen me talking
about it in previous videos so we're not
gonna get too bogged down with it sword
up was brought into the team from the
lpl a veteran superstar support who
would just played in a world's final
literally the pinnacle of league of
legends in the regular season with
bjergsen as their coach tsm finished
second in spring that year and first in
summer but were unable to convert that
form when it came to playoffs failing to
qualify for worlds for the third time in
four years and then people started
leaving first it was tsm's president
lena bjerksen went to team liquid to
become a player again and then just
before the season started general
manager parth was gone too their
offseason was also plagued by a very
public bust-up between doublelift and
tsm ceo reggie with doublelift accusing
his former boss of bullying tsm staff
and players we've done a whole bunch of
videos on that but at the moment we're
waiting on the findings of a riot
investigation and a tsm internal
investigation into the matter now i
don't care how big or tough your org is
that is a rough start for anyone it also
came at a time when tsm had brought
unproven chinese talent into the team
while kaidua and shenya have had
promising flourishes at times they've
not been the saviors that some fans had
hoped for in fact they've sometimes
managed to get themselves wrapped up in
the drama themselves both players have
been moved to the academy teams at
various points and in february a reddit
post claimed to show the transcript of
an alleged phone call between shenyi and
a former teammate where shenyi appears
to claim that tsm didn't think his shot
calling was good enough between the
losses and the drama we thought that
things couldn't get any worse for tsm
but then their long-standing coach peter
zhang was fired amid allegations that he
was accepting money to ensure players a
spot on the team acting as both agent
and coach look tsm not making playoffs
is a shock to anyone who's watched the
lcs for more than five years but if you
add up all the [ __ ] that's happened over
the past six months
it starts to make a bit of sense there's
two questions now what went wrong and
what will tsm do next well the first
question can only really be answered by
people close to the team but from the
outside looking in it seems like things
have crumbled from the top down the
culture at the top of the orc has been
shaken up a lot over the past year with
some key figures leaving maybe that's
had an effect on the players or maybe
it's something else entirely but
something definitely seemed wrong with
tsm's management when former president
lena claimed that former general manager
path literally didn't want this roster
of players in the first place that's not
great for upper management but imagine
being one of the players and hearing
that being a tsm player has come with
immense pressure and expectation in the
best of years imagine being one now team
liquid owner steve aaron set was
recently asked what he would do if he
was in charge of tsm to fix the problem
he spoke of rebuilding trust of
establishing leadership but when it came
to the team itself he didn't hold back i
would just rebuild the roster probably
i have no idea what's going on over
there i really don't so i don't want to
like make it seem like i do uh i really
don't but at least from outside looking
in and things on reddit and you know
comments and passive aggressiveness and
just all the back and forth and drama
and stuff it just feels like
time to just rebuild that makes sense
but i guess the next question is when do
you do it are tsm really going to blow
up their whole roster before summer what
if the players aren't the problem what
if it's the staff or the environment
it's hard to tell i watch tsm legends
every single week and although you can
glean some insight into the inner
workings of the org it's obviously still
a sanitized version for the public in
csm's end of split twitter post they
told fans they were looking forward to
showing them something different in the
summer that could mean different
personnel it could mean a different
performance it could just be something
to give fans hope who knows i think it's
important to give other teams credit too
it's not like they've not improved team
liquid for example have finally put the
fourth place memes behind them in recent
years and look like genuine contenders
to win any split cloud9 have continued
to be solid where tsm have faltered
especially at worlds 100 thieves are
looking to prove to everyone that their
title win last summer wasn't just a
fluke that they're here to stay in fact
you could even argue that they've
replaced tsm in the big three teams
around tsm have improved over the last
few years while tsm themselves have
fallen off a bit of a cliff which makes
the whole thing look even more dramatic
but as tsm said in their twitter post
2022 isn't over yet there is still time
to turn things around but the team not
making playoffs for the first time ever
is huge the question now is will it be
remembered as the moment tsm fixed
things and righted the ship or just
another landmark in their ongoing
descent
well it's official tsm have had their
worst ever split in the lcs in their
nine year history
well it's official
well it's official tsm have had their